and the book has been a huge success so
that's all but I have to say not
everyone has been that thrilled by the
publication of the book President Trump
made a rare foray into the world Twitter
about your about your book
crooked Hillary Clinton blames everybody
and everything for herself relation
shock she lost the debates in Oster
direction and you had a very good reply
are you tempted to ignore his tweets
well you know I ignore a lot of them
because there are so many you could not
respond to all of them this one in
particular I said well I've also written
a children's book that you may find no I
haven't heard back yet but but I do
respond when I think you know what he
has said is hurtful and unfair and
really causing problems for people and I
sometimes but rarely tweet at him so we
had this horrible hurricane in Puerto
Rico which is a part of the United
States and three and a half million
people live there and nothing was
happening so I did tweet at him and at
the Defense Department basically to say
you know send the Navy and send the
hospital ship and you know within a day
or two or three they actually did it so
but that's what I think has he set the
agenda but you do presumably you didn't
tweet that much before he's he's brought
the world to Twitter to try and explain
complex things in just a few words well
he has tweeted for a while but you're
right that he tries to talk about issues
that are very complex he uses it to
mostly attack people insult criticize
people the most dangerous thing he does
is conduct diplomacy on Twitter so he is
trading insults with Kim jong-un which
is like just catnip for Kim jong-un he
loves that the idea that he's in a
Twitter insult fest with the president
the United States
so he does things that are truly not
only upsetting but kind of inexplicable
and some of it just goes on answered and
others I answer and many many people do
as well
[Music]